[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day we're
talking about three stories today Alex
Jones was banned from YouTube Ronda
Rousey made her WWE Raw debut and reddit
users are talking about something called
P gasm let's get into it I want to start
with Ronda Rousey here WWE Raw debut she
was an MMA fighter undefeated lost to
Holly Holm famously Jordan you remember
yeah now she's Ryan what do you think I
think it's great I think it's cool
people were asking why is this a big
deal too because the first time that
she's wrestled on Monday Night Raw which
is like the weekly show and previous to
that she's only been on the
pay-per-views but they were like pumping
her up so much right so well this one
seems way less choreographed and
polished and or fake than other ones
I've seen like it seemed like she was
like hurting her around it's crazy it is
fake it's like the circus right like
those tricks that they do are still
tricks yes I think between the ropes
she's very sloppy and I think that she
was almost a hazard and she was not
completing a lot of moves that is my
take on it I think that all she was
doing was playing up that hey I was a
boxer thing with the with the punches
you don't think this is fun to watch I
think that it was just raw aggressive
she's running through the women's
division which is the best that it's
ever been and she's Hampton as the UFC
champ former UFC champion she's just
destroying people I feel bad for the
women who's really can wrestle between
the ropes and I feel like they're just
using her of course she's a big man so
they're gonna come in have a blast do it
all the women are like oh she's the
she's a good fighter but she's not a
great wrestler how's her sword work you
also had a sword now with a sword game
on you know it's come back I don't think
speaking of fleek perhaps the most unfit
person of all time Alex Jones
and his website and YouTube channel
Infowars we've been banned from many
platforms it's banned from stitcher
banned from Apple banned from Facebook
now banned from YouTube where he had 2
million subscribers he's the famous
conspiracy theorist he has spread and
fake news violated the terms of the
service agreement of these platforms and
now he's been banned is the accusation
what do we think it is I genuinely
thought he would have gone away years
ago just because I was like those vocal
cords felt like his died I hate him been
his diaphragm very strong very strong
son that's us I think his sons too scary
oh yes yeah yes three kids and his son
looks exactly like him just like a
miniature version it's not even he looks
like an old man that's just like and
he's yelling he's doing he brings him on
the show he's like 12 years old crazy so
Alex Jones I think is gonna die of a
heart attack like you did see he's right
he's so angry I seen a man have our
attack and he did not look as red as his
son yelling about like middle school
issues I think YouTube is right here I
think that they're right and I'm not
going to be like oh they should have
done this a while ago they did it when
they needed to do it and I'm all for it
and to those two million people that
liked Alex Jones
welcome aboard baby yeah you're all
subscribers now yes yes they just moved
them all over I hope they don't even
have to click we'll just start showing
up yeah YouTube if you could make that
happen any conspiracy theories for our
new subscribers what's the one about
Beyonce oh well Beyonce the theory is
that Solange is Beyonce's daughter
whereas in real life Solange is her
sister got it yes
pretty sure so there's that one there's
a theory that Michael Jackson and LaToya
Jackson are the same person whereas in
real life they're brother and sister
once again it's it's as if you're
clarifying but I feel like you're asking
[Laughter]
reddit users are calling it a P gasm
it's the phenomenon when especially for
women when you hold the sensations here
innate so long but then when you do
finally go
it feels so pleasurable it is
experienced as an orgasm happened to me
also so I think it's just holding if it
just feels so good the pleasure is
equivalent to an orgasm versus is an
actual orgasm and the release is a
better feeling than half the man I've
been with actually an orgasm or is it
just the it feels that good I'm not sure
I know what an orgasm holding my pee
feels great I think some people are
actually experiencing orgasm because
like I was reading like the bladder like
the wires are like it's so bad gonna but
like the bladder pushes against parts
okay so those are confusing not the a
UTI you're like you that's your urinary
tract but that's not where the it's all
very confusing I'm sorry I don't know I
white male I will agree everything's
confusing down there and I think that
this story really just speaks to how bad
men are at sex is where the women are
like I think I had an orgasm like you
went to the bathroom have you guys ever
had to pee so bad right so then you
finally let it go and you're like oh but
maybe I can stop and you can't stop why
would you want to stop as I was doing it
in class myself in seventh grade had to
go so bad and finally I remember this in
science class we heard about a man whose
bladder exploded and he died so I was
like I think if I want to live I have to
let a little go the pressure will stop
you can't here's the thing I was wearing
these like black stretchy pants
it sucked it all smells still yeah but I
believe I was on the bus and I was like
what smells like piss and I was like
yeah what smells like that was your
first yes and Ashley brings up a good
point is that doctors are saying do not
do this do not try this it is very bad
for your organs I don't know about the
bladder exploding but it is some
astronomer who in a party held his head
[Music]
there's a Galileo
I need to hold just be any time I like
we can bring the stories together Jordan
you have a shout out for us
oh yes okay
Desiree says I feel like they're getting
more comfortable with each other
diggin it let us pray they I have Joe
listen Sarah Taylor Myers from Rose
battle and I'm gonna ask him for
questions all right so this whole what I
would have did the theme of it it's
relationships oh this is it I said y'all
married let's go for it okay so with the
relationship let's go
my answer is anal to everything listen
that actually fits perfectly for the
first question all right the first
question what would you do if someone
was using your partner's picture to
catfish people I'm kind of flattered I
think it would be nice yeah yeah let
people think that they're talking to my
wife mm-hmm cuz they're not hopefully
yeah right no they're not talking to me
yeah I would I would I would embrace
that person and I would say good for you
and let me know I get half of anything
you make off of this catfish first of
all cats fishes aren't for money it's
usually for sexual purposes and to the
person arrives they realize oh yeah oh
I'm not sleeping with anybody
oh okay I guess I'm not that to me was
cash for what I would do
okay if somebody's catfishing using my
lady's picture I would go all out and I
would go all in and try to try to get
with their offering meaning I would say
hey what's up baby
didn't you my wife and I would just
completely dirty-talking up like I'm
assuming this is my actual wife all
right because I was like hey man maybe
we did let and I would go and I'm like
hey so you come to the movies just
tonight and then when she's standing up
I'm like hey does anybody see my wife
and they would go to the point where
basically I would end up filing a
missing
on the catfishing that's a way better
answer that I had what would you do if
your partner prepared your favorite meal
once a month but it always tasted awful
yes thank you that is something that Joe
would do anyway he never cooks no good I
have come from like an Irish family we
just boiled things boil it I can make it
you made my meal and it wasn't that
great
yeah I'd eat it would you be gradually
eat it it would be grudgingly eat it and
then I would probably wait a few hours
and then go get something else see if
you made my favorite meal which is
spaghetti yeah chicken farm which isn't
hard and it tasted horrible
I would still appreciate it I would I
would appreciate it I would maybe kind
of flip it out the window like in Roma
Christmas vacation where she's doing
that one of those keep a window open
yeah baby it's cold out no and I'm a
little hot what I would do if my lady
makes me some and I don't like it
fall I pull a Dick Van Dyke on it you
[Laughter]
later
did you fall and I know my wife she said
did you follow a purpose earlier said
yes because I love you
what would you do if you and your
partner swapped bodies Freaky Friday I
would rather not say you go first what
would you do if you were in there I
would just do Joe's tour dates and
collect those checks put the AC unit
into the window yeah they're all the
stuff that I've been putting off because
I I can't lift high I'd reach a lot of
stuff from top shelf
I'll let you answer no Joe I mean I
would enjoy it I feel like Sarah's a
very beautiful sexy woman I feel like I
could get a lot of like I would use it
to my advantage I'd be around getting
meals bought for me and drinks it's not
happening right now
I'm a mini leather skirt not how to
cleave in situation really oh man I'll
get weird thank you all for being on
what I would've did you enjoy yourselves
every time don't forget to check them
out on tonight's episode of roast Baloo
will they be battling each other get
married
crazy 10:00 9:00 central and if you miss
it then hey check it out on the CC app
or you can watch it on cc.com how to
orgasm without touching yourself just
breathing techniques it works without
with is friggin awesome
really guys really cool send you away
I'll see you next time on every damn day
[Music]
you